We've seen a couple of cases of direct variation, so let's look at inverse
variation. Earlier we determined that the speed of a vehicle and the driving
time were inversely related. If we drive really fast, then we don't need as much
time to get to our final destination. If a car takes 20 minutes to travel some
distance at 45 miles per hour, how long would it take that same car to travel
the same exact distance driving at 60 miles per hour? We want to be very careful
though. We don't want to use this proportion. This is for direct variation. This
proportion would say that if we drive faster, then it would take longer to get
somewhere. But we know this is not true. We know if we drive faster, then our
time spent driving decreases. So instead of doing this, we can flip this second
fraction over. If we flip the second fraction over, we can see that our speed
now would be decreasing. If we drive slower, then it should take longer amount
of time to get there. This also fits with our notion of speed and time. If speed
increases, time decreases. Likewise if speed decreases, as in this case, then we
know that we should expect to drive longer. Time increases. For inverse
variation, we always want to put the other quantity in the opposite position.
We'll need to flip the fraction that varies inversely. So what do you think, how
long would it take us to drive?